[Musique]
du geste large et puissant que zola dans
la terre donne à son laboureur l'auto
journal d'idées et d'actions va lancer à
travers la france aujourd'hui les
inconscients et rude summer d'énergie
que son os grand routier professionnel
vous amis coureurs qui est des êtres
trois semaines durant notre porte parole
à travers la france entière que nos
voeux les plus ardents vous accompagne
la grande bataille que vous allez livrer
au soleil à la chaleur à la fraîcheur
des nuits au traîtrise déroute obscur
que la lutte vous soit favorable
rapporter un peu de cette moisson dorée
que je jette largement pour vous
l'oeuvre que nous voulons accomplir
c'est vous qui serez chargé pendant
trois semaines
vous êtes les rues des inconscients
summer d'énergie au passage desquels la
fois sportive va triompher une fois de
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
6 juillet 2002 palais des congrès du
luxembourg le tour de france est à
l'aube de son centenaire
cinquante deux chaînes de télévision
cinquante stations de radio plus de 400
journaux vont trois semaines durant
faire voir écouter lire l'épreuve phare
du cyclisme international
elle est aujourd'hui la troisième au
rang des spectacles sportifs les plus
suivis
après les jeux olympiques et la coupe du
monde de football face à ce gigantesque
show sportif certes mais devenu aussi
grâce à son hypermédiatisation le
terrain d'énormes enjeux commerciaux et
financiers
que reste-t-il de l'épreuve créée en
1903 le sport lui même n'y at il pas
perdu une partie de son âme
desgrange y reconnaître itil ces petits
gars les légendaires forçats de la route
il y à fort à parier que le père
fondateur du tour de france non
seulement se féliciterait d'une telle
évolution
mais ils trouveraient surtout la
confirmation de sa géniale trouvaille
une poule aux oeufs d'or qui permit à
son journal l'auto et à sa fille
l'équipe de traverser un siècle
d'histoire la relation argent médias et
sport et fondatrice du spectacle sportif
et la fabrication de sa légende frappe
par son extrême capacité à profiter de
tous les outils médiatiques apparu
depuis press photo cinéma radio et
télévision
le tour de france est de la télé réalité
2 et sportive réalité vous vous montrez
cette fois et c'est impressionnant aux
téléspectateurs ce que sont les efforts
les souffrances les drames la dureté de
ce que l'on demande aux coureurs tout ça
le spectateur le voit le comprend le
partage alors que début du siècle des
ehpad radio il n'y a pas de télévision
les journalistes
rendez compte par la plume naturellement
et ce soit eux effectivement qui ont
fait le l'histoire la légende le mythe
du cyclisme le sport spectacle doit sa
naissance à une invention industrielle
la
en france ce sont les fabricants de
vélos qui organise dès 1860 les
premières compétitions dans le but de
promouvoir ses moyens de locomotion
révolutionnaire mais susciter l'intérêt
de gens aisés qui pratiquent ce passe
temps qu'ils appellent le sport ne
suffit pas il faut convaincre le plus
grand nombre de la halle et l'idée de
créer une presse à grand tirage
exclusivement consacré au sport et à la
réclame pour les marques de cycles
le succès est phénoménal entre 1890 et
1900 la france passe de dix mille
propriétaires de bicyclette à un million
au début du siècle dernier
il n'existe qu'un seul quotidien sportif
sur la place de paris le vélo
son directeur pierre giffard qui est
aussi organisateur de courses comme le
paris brest paris ne s'en tient pas
qu'aux pauvres
outré par l'injustice faite au capitaine
dreyfus il engage sa plume
publiquement il oublie quelque chose
d'essentiel c'est que sont plus forts
commanditaires le baron de dion est
nettement à la tête je dirais d'une
croisade anti dreyfusards et de dion
devant cette situation qui pompent
puisqu'il en est à 6 eh bien nous allons
retirer nos vies nous allons retirer
notre argent à giffard et nous allons
créer notre propre au journal et
effectivement ils créent août au vélo le
16 octobre 1901 nouveau quotidien jaune
l'auto vélo sort dans les kiosques c'est
la grand mère de l'actuelle équipe
la direction du journal est confiée à
henri desgrange chroniqueur sportif
ancien recordman de l'heure sur tricycle
l'administration est assurée par victor
gaudet
et rend le thé l'homme d'action jeudi le
bal directeur le patron tout ce qui
était le sport est mort et bon père
était le patron c'est tout ce qu est l
argent les compter l'argent
ce couple qui s'entendait à merveille
car les deux hommes étaient ex en
aliments complémentaires
il n'ya place que pour un seul titre il
ya une urgence il faut couler l'autre le
plus vite possible
pas forcément pour le coup les mets ont
au moins pour tenir pour vivre le vélo
organisée quelques épreuves des grands
jeux va en organiser des centaines
la lutte entre les deux quotidiens est
acharnée début 1902 henri desgrange fait
bondir les ventes de l'auto vélo en
soufflant l'organisation du paris brest
paris à son concurrent le directeur du
vélo réplique en attaquant pur plagiat
de titres par décision de justice
l'auto vélo devient l'auto tout court et
voit sa cote de popularité sombre et
dangereusement
[Musique]
et font une réelle qu il faut récupérer
absolument la clientèle
deux cyclistes qui est essentiel encore
une fois c'est bien gentil le loto
l'industrie ça apporte de l'argent mais
ça n'importe pas de lecteur pas encore
le public n'est pas encore habitué à
l'automobile il ya un tas de choses on
craint l'automobile ont craint un avion
mais c'est pas le public populaire et le
public peuple et on le trouve avec tous
cyclistes le 20 novembre 1902 un des
jeunes journalistes de desgranges géo
lefèvre lance en désespoir de cause une
idée inouïe un tour de france cycliste
par étapes
aucun coureur n'a fait 2500 kilomètres
en dehors des six jours c'est-à-dire
dans un cadre très confiné sur une piste
de 200 m à l'abri des difficultés à
l'abri des intempéries et d'hôtes en
1903 la france on ne sait pas vraiment
ce que c'est d'un village à l'autre de
20 km à la parcelle inconnue c'est
quasiment en amérique la prise de
risques est totale si je refais quelle
idée c'est le grand choc a été captée et
c'est mon père qui a décidé alors ils
sont partis tous les deux ans margot les
amap et la torride et moment mon père
les a écoutés et leur a dit il y avait
un gros tous rejeté hollywood y voilà
les clés de mon coffre
le 1er juillet 1903 emile s'ourdit
reporter au quotidien le journal vient
en curieux les grands je me souviens
qu'on est arrivé à montjaux casser le
réveil matin dit qu'il y avait 150 à 200
personnes peut-être pas plus
c'était simplement comme le départ une
pousse d'une petite vie d'une kermesse
rien du tout moi je vois encore gala
avec le tout enfermé puis alors les bots
you qui ceinturent être y avait aux
ateliers nos jours
pottier fischer le départ est donné par
un coup de vent devait exactement à 3h16
s'était pas plaint car c'était 3e set
c'est à géo lefèvre l'inventeur du
concept de la course que l'auto a confié
la tâche d'essuyer les plâtres premier
tour de france a eu en tout et pour tout
comme directeur de la course comme
surveillant sur la route comme
journaliste suiveurs et chargés de
comptes rendus par les différents
journaux il y avait une seule personne
c'était moi et mes 26 effet tôt il est
tout seul il a même pas de voiture pour
le premier tour de france j'ai est
inconcevable quand on pense un peu un
tour de france dirigée par l'homme qui a
pas de voiture avec son vélo pour
devancer le plateau pour le retrouver
faire un toit un pointage et puis il va
reprendre le fameux ces seuils sont
fiers quand on pense à ça c'est pas
c'est pas pour ça plus lente mais la
nuit est tombée
tout d'un coup des petits feux follets
carrie les bruits de grelots des
silhouettes et un peloton de 2 ou france
aux marines j'arrête quête vous gare un
potier au couturier
je les fais arrêter j'avais un timbre
humide caoutchouc et en prendre à ce jeu
les et poinçonnet sur la main ils sont
partis j'ai repris ce train là où je
pouvais trouver un express rapid croq
tamouls arrivés à lyon
j'arrive sur le quai sur les pavés du
quai de la soul il avait cinq à six
cents personnes égarées étaient déjà
arrivés
[Applaudissements]
dix-huit jours plus tard l'auto a gagné
son pari
vingt mille spectateurs attendent les
coureurs sur le parc des princes le
vainqueur maurice garin en poche une
somme de 12 mille francs soit près de
six ans de salaire d'un ouvrier
l'édition spéciale du journal s'est
vendu à 130 mille exemplaires le vélo
son concurrent déclarera forfait
définitivement quelques mois plus tard
ce qui est inventé c'est le financement
d'une course parce que le journal qui
propose l'organisons cette course va la
financer pourquoi la finance t-il tout
simplement parce que il espère gagner
des lecteurs lesquels lecteurs s'ils
sont spectateurs ne voient qu'un instant
de la course comme nous voyons
aujourd'hui passer de manière
extrêmement furtive des coureurs qui se
déplacent n'y voyant qu'un instant or en
quoi le journal at il la possibilité de
trouver de l'intérêt c'est que il
raconte une course à ceux qui n'en voit
qu'un événement extra
fautif géo lefèvre vient en trois
semaines d'inventer le reportage sportif
transformant les spectateurs frustrés en
lecteur passionné par cette nouvelle
épopée moderne mais des critiques
s'élèvent la marque de cycles la
française pour laquelle court garin n'a
pas hésité à se livrer à des
irrégularités dépannage et
ravitaillement illicites changement de
vélo devant lesquels les organisateurs
ont fermé les yeux
la française est un des plus gros
annonceurs de l'auto le lecteur finances
le journal
mais le journal trouve un financement à
travers la lettre à travers des
annonceurs et ça c'est incontestablement
une invention très importante parce que
ça va donner une véritable force
financière à la course et ça va lui
donner la possibilité de traverser un
siècle
lors de ce second tour de france l'auto
ne mesure pas encore les conséquences de
la popularité de l'épreuve et les
débordements qu'elle peut provoquer
aussi bien de la part des coureurs et de
leurs employeurs les marques de cycles
que de la part des populations gagné par
un enthousiasme partisans
[Musique]
dans l'étape paris lyon il ya des
coureurs qui ont pris le train 1
il ya des voitures qui rentrait sur les
concurrents impro les en l'air et
le peloton est passé en chutant
saint-etienne alors là on avait mis les
clous 1 pour que les gens réparer
pendant qu'ils réparent et on est sortir
coup de gourdin 1 pour aider des
coureurs à réparer il n'a fallu que les
organisateurs sorte le revolver pour
tirer un et permettent la suite on que
c'était et ça recommence et dans l'étape
marseille toulouse 1
là c'était plus un coureur stéphanois
c'est un coureur de la région des
semaines inquiète aider et on a
recommencé avec le tour de france est
terminée et sa seconde édition aura je
le crains bien était la dernière
il sera mort de son succès des patients
aveugles qui leur a déchaîné des injures
et des salles soupçons qui nous a valu
des ignorants et des méchants et
pourtant il nous a semblé il nous semble
encore que nous avons édifié avec cette
grande épreuve le monument le plus
durable le plus important du sport
cycliste
[Musique]
ce tour de france ne sera pas le dernier
mais il reflète à merveille le paradoxe
devant lequel des granges va se trouver
confronté
jusque dans les années 30 pour le
lecteur il n'y a pas de course de
spectacles de légende sans loyauté
sportive et sans suspense
al'inverse le lectorat ne suffisant pas
à financer les preuves il est impossible
de se passer des marques de cycles qui
pour des raisons publicitaires ne
reculent devant aucune tricherie des
granges organisateurs sportifs va devoir
sans cesse batailler contre les
manigances des industriels des granges
patrons de presse va de son côté
peaufiner sa légende lui inventer de
nouvelles péripéties devant l'herald
angoisse qui l'ont poussé devant l'afld
allemand de certains sur le bord de la
route à bout de forces
j'ai senti au coin de mon oeil la larme
à la fois amer et bienfaisante
cette alarme que l'on a quelques fois au
théâtre lorsque l'on croit que c'est
arrivé j'ai même senti
il faut que je la vous que tous ces
hommes avaient dépassé largement les
limites de leur résistance
j'ai senti comme un véritable remords et
j'ai eu peur très peur d'avoir dépassé
les limites
en 1906 desgranges qui cherchent à
innover toujours plus au caire les
autorités allemandes le droit de faire
étape à metz capitale de la lorraine
occupé depuis 1870 c'est à cette
occasion que le directeur de l'auto va
prendre conscience de la dimension
symbolique extra sportive de sa course
le tour de france c'est le tour de la
france de tous les français
lorrains et alsaciens compris et ils
vivent en particulier cette pénétration
dans les territoires blessés
comme déjà quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre du retour certains chantent la
marseillaise
d'autres manifestent leur émotion à
travers d'une arme
donc on voit comment travers ce seul
épisode le tour de france confronte
finalement le public à autre chose que
la course et c'est ça qui rend je trouve
personnellement la course si importante
et qui ont fait finalement un objet de
notre patrimoine
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
variez le récit créer le suspense sont
les impératifs pour attirer le lectorat
très vite le tour s'émancipe de son
tracé initial explorant de nouvelles
villes étapes
s'attaquant au relief montagneux en 1910
desgranges dépêche l'un de ses
journalistes pour reconnaître le col du
tourmalet l'homme manque d'y laisser sa
vie concernant le tour 1910 le tracé d
autant plus difficile qu on s'aventurait
dans une région qui était pas une
mythologie pyrène les pyrénées il y
avait des ours y avait des aigles on
savait pas où on allait ça me paraissait
invraisemblable aux spectateurs y avait
un suspense est-ce qu'ils allaient y
arriver c'était démesuré
le 22 juillet 1910 victor breyer
n'envoyer de l'auto est au sommet du
tourmalet un coureur se présente c'est
octave lapize qui est le premier coureur
est repassé devant victor breyer tu lui
poses la question la plus typique qui
soit celle du disque
la pise comment ça va vous pensez
l'autre le prends deux volets vous êtes
tous des assassins et vous elle dira dr
henry est alors derrière lui il ya eu un
grand vide en attendu pendant un quart
d'heure votre poids et pretoria disent
ça n'est pas possible
mais pour ça a été tellement belle qui
l'a télégraphié rue des grandes qui
était à paris il henri desgranges qui
était un homme très très dur a dit
rupture brière tous les coureurs qui
arriveront à bayonne on en droit de
reprendre le départ de l'ot matin pour
une fois il a éliminé personnes
desgrange un peu comme le directeur d'un
cirque est sans cesse à la recherche de
nouveaux numéros de nouveaux lieux
l'exploit après les pyrénées il passe
aux alpes
ô col bayard au tourmalet je ne
faillirai pas à mon devoir en proclamant
qu'à côté du galibier vous êtes de la
pâle et vulgaire bibine
devant ce géant il n'ya plus qu'à tirer
son bonnet et à saluer bien bas nous
apercevions au dessous de nous des
fourmis qui avançaient c'était nous
sommes occupés à grignoter le monstre
des dents de leurs pédales il fait là
haut un froid de canard et lorsque
georges et passe après avoir mis son
petit vainqueur sur la tête du monstre
lorsqu'ils passent près de nous salles
la moustache plein de morgue et des
nourritures du dernier contrôle et le
maillot ça l'idée pourriture du dernier
ruisseau ou en âge il s'est vautré ils
nous jettent affreux mais augustin
ça vous en bouche un coin
on
[Applaudissements]
l'auto est seul à pouvoir rendre compte
de la course dès le lendemain des étapes
le lecteur peut certes mettre des
visages sur les coureurs grâce à la
photographie ou les voir en action grâce
au cinématographe présent sur le tour
depuis 1903 mais avec une dizaine de
jours de retard sur l'événement des
granges et maître de son récit c'est lui
qui fabrique l'épopée
un des premiers gestes de des granges
c'est très curieux c'est de construire
des stèle à la mémoire de ces grands
coureurs des premières selles c'est le
ballon d'alsace pour potier en 1907
un peu comme si la course est tout en
mesure de créer une sorte d'univers de
perfection un peu d'olympie voulait
totalement idéal où coexisteraient les
grands champions dont la mémoire est
susceptible de traverser le temps
[Musique]
l'hélium
ici en 1913 eugène christophe répara à
la france sa force de bicyclette il
abandonna point fournissant ainsi un
exemple de volonté sublime parce que je
n'ai pas changé de tubes géré à bouter
mon tube québec aceq un bout de
ferraille
et puis les officiels étaient là ils ont
payé il y avait trois officiels qui
était comme trois statues de bouddha
membres qui est déjà sur moi je n'allais
pas me prêter la main alors moi avec le
cas fin ça me tortille est donc en tous
sens j'avais plutôt les larmes aux yeux
un ça faisait drôle savez j'étais froid
c'était lugubre lui aussi bientôt je
vais je crois 18 d'avancé au classement
général
mais finalement j'ai fini à quatre ans
de retard le départ du 12e tour de
france le 12 juin 1914 coïncide avec
l'assassinât de l'archiduc d'autriche à
sarajevo
à peine deux mois plus tard la
mobilisation générale était d'éclat le
grand match les petits gars mes p'tits
gars chéri mes p'tits gars français
écoutez moi depuis quatorze ans que
l'auto paraît tous les jours
il ne vous a jamais donné de mauvais
conseil 1 alors écoutez moi les
prussiens sont des c'est un gros
match que vous avez à disputer mais
méfiez vous quand votre cross sera sur
leur poitrine
ils vous demanderont pardon ne vous
laissez pas faire enfoncer sans pitié
alliant le geste à la parole
desgrange décide de s'engager à l'âge de
50 ans il est envoyé dans la mèche dont
il va terminer la guerre avec les petits
comme il dit lui même prenait soldats
dans les tranchées
est ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'il le continue le journaliste qui l'a
toujours été puisqu'il bat tous les
jours
écrire ses papiers compris dans les
tranchées ça donne une idée du bonhomme
c'est quand même exception
la guerre de 14-18 est aussi une
hécatombe pour les cyclistes de l'âge de
fer du tour de france lapize petit
breton faber et beaucoup d'autres ont
disparu au combat
pour ce 13e tour celui de la reprise des
granges donne le ton dans son éditorial
je voudrais que les foules accourus de
toute part sur leur passage leur fasse
les choses ovation qu'il mérite
je voudrais qu'elle vienne la plus en
pèlerinage qu'au spectacle qu'elle salue
tous ces vaillants kelly viennent
chercher ceux qui vont remplacer les
chéris que les ont ravi à nos
tendresse strasbourg metz et ce n'est
pas un rêve nous allons là bas chez nous
nous verrons de belfort à haguenau toute
la ligne bleue des vosges qu'avant la
guerre nous contemplions à notre droite
nous allonger le rhin
c'est lors de ce tour dit 919
qu'alphonse baugé le directeur des
cycles halcyon souffle une idée à
desgrange alim chez les grands héros
j'estime que le courant qu'un premier
plâtre original et devrait avoir un
maillot spécial halloween chez zig parce
que des granges et d'appeler monsieur
alphonse bol il l'a pas saisie félix
j'avais raison alors qu'on préfère c'est
pas moi qui n'améliore spécial fois pas
un maillot femmes maillot jaune quoi
comme lotto
[Musique]
et au jour
le plus éclatant n'est symbole le plus
absolu c'est le maillot jaune c'est la
lumière c'est le soleil c'est la vie et
ce maillot jaune ine au moment idéal il
n'y en 1919
après l'effroyable la guerre de 14 18 le
pays avait besoin d'un symbole et ce
symbole vient du tour de france c'est le
maillot jaune
[Musique]
ma mort
la première image de coureur celle du
début du 20e siècle
c'est quelqu'un qui a une culture de la
force et qui a une culture du monde
ouvrier et les métaphores qui sont
utilisées par les journalistes et en
particulier par des granges temps des
métaphores animales
ce sont des boeufs de la bourse ce sont
des sangliers ce sont des sortes de
bêtes de force elles vont changer et
elles vont aller vers des images
beaucoup plus fine beaucoup plus
technique ou la souplesse ou le côté
aérien de coureurs va être dominant par
exemple à la métaphore du sanglier va
faire place la métaphore du lévrier où
la métaphore du pur sang ce qui est tout
à fait différent ce qui renvoie à des
cordes fin à décor beaucoup d'ailiers à
décor beaucoup plus léger ce sont les
corps des années 20 des années 30 en
particulier ceux des frères pélissier
henri pélissier est la star du tout en
l'année suivante c'est une toute autre
affaire qui les rend célèbre lui et son
frère francis alors qu'ils savent qu'ils
ne peuvent plus gagner le tour ils
prennent prétexte d'une altercation avec
henri desgrange pour annoncer leur a bon
dos
la présence sur l'épreuve de l'écrivain
reporter albert londres dont le livre
sur le bagne de cayenne nord provoque à
la fermeture tombe à pic pour les deux
compères
une rencontre est à ranger qui
débouchera sur le premier récit
littéraire du tour de france les forçats
de la route
ce que nous ne ferions pas faire à des
mules et nous faisons on n'est pas des
fainéants mais non de dieu qu'on ne nous
embête pas je m'appelle pélissier non
pas à tort un jour viendra où nous
mettrons du plan dans les poches parce
qu ils prétendront que dieu a fait
l'homme trop léger ce qui est important
c'est qu'effectivement les frères
pélissier avait déjà loupé à ils disent
tout sur le dopage
tout ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui tout ce
qu'on apprend aujourd'hui si vous
relisez albert londres à l'époque et
tout il ya le nom des produits et et
henri desgrange ne henri henri pélissier
ne cache pas le lien on peut pas le
faire tourner en france si on prend pas
c'est ça le prix c'est pas possible de
faire le tour de france sans cela dans
un éditorial cinglant des granges
réplique traitant les policiers qu'ils
comparaient l'année précédente à des
deux bus 6 ou d'émané du vélo de
millionnaires souffrent d'une mauvaise
préparation physique on peut parler de
forçats de la route dans certains cas
les pétitions porter le faire de manière
un peu excessive dans la plaie mais 470
km qui pleuvent qui vante avec beaucoup
de crevaisons avec l'obligation de
réparer soi-même
une fois que vous avez épuisé les moyens
réglementaires que vous êtes livré à
vous-même que des coureurs cours avec le
vélo sur le bras pour essayer de
terminer les délais le tour et peut être
infernale c'était à la fois admirable et
monstrueux eh bien c'était ça qui était
devenu el tarf ans c'était vraiment le
sacrifice absolue de son être physique
de son être moral avec tes grands jeux
nous allions trop loin parce que dans le
fond le public mais des grands chantiers
et
et ces épopées le grison en 1925
c'est le cinématographe qui investit la
course pour tourner une fiction
le roi de la
non
les spectateurs des salles obscures
peuvent ainsi voir l'acteur bisco arrivé
en triomphe au parc des princes suivi du
véritable vainqueur ottavio bottecchia
qui ne dédaignant pas les premières
publicités extra sportives sur le tour
livre le secret de son doping personnel
[Musique]
oh
en ce début des années 20 le tandem
victor gaudet et henri desgrange règne
sur le monde du spectacle sportif
outre le tour de france et le journal le
groupe l'auto possède le parc des
princes et le vélodrome d'hiver
[Musique]
mais en 1926 victor hugo des
propriétaires de la presque totalité des
actions de cet empire décède laissant à
son fils aîné maurice la responsabilité
financière du groupe
ce qui ne sera pas sans conséquence sur
le déclin et la chute du journal au même
moment le fils cadet jacques fait ses
premières armes de reporter à l'auto
auprès d'henri desgrange inaugure en 60
ans de carrière au service du tour de
france m'enfin règne qui aimait mais la
belle ville et jolies femmes et les
choses' objet elle est très jolie
voiture était de ce fait font sciemment
dépenser alors ça ne pouvait pas
beaucoup des granges et grands la
parodie sommes absolument l'affection et
est par conséquent on sait d'avancé
comme ça dans la vie
[Musique]
les tours des années 20 tous remportés
par des coureurs étrangers recrutés par
les équipes de marques deviennent de
plus en plus populaire en europe
mais pour les organisateurs ce succès
est dangereusement paradoxal car les
victoires à répétition de champion belge
et luxembourgeois provoque une
désaffection du public français du bord
des routes et surtout une stagnation des
ventes du journal
mais le plus inquiétant pour henri
desgrange c'est d'assister impuissant à
la stratégie de ses équipes de marque
qui anéantit le suspense de la course
basée selon lui sur le combat
d'individus à armes égales et la
transforme en pronostics bassement
commerciaux
et marques de sucre qui équipaient les
coureurs quittent l est les patrons des
équipes de quoi jouer un rôle capital
parce que vivement la victoire pour eux
ça représentait la bande des vélos
c'était la vie ou la mort alors cessé et
constructeur de cycles sont devenus des
gens qui commençaient à chercher à
obtenir les meilleurs résultats à
n'importe quel moyen
et finalement les tours de france de la
fin des années 20 s'abîmer peuple se
dégradèrent je sentais même alors que
j'arrivais à la toute jeune et l iran le
sens c'est bien aussi
l'auto propriétaire du tour de france
l'un depuis la disparition du vélo aucun
concurrent sérieux qui menacerait son
contrôle sur l'information sportive mais
un nouveau média vient troubler son
monopole la radio
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si l'on sait déjà enregistré les voix la
lourdeur des premiers appareils en
interdit la mobilité mais depuis 1923
les auditeurs peuvent suivre en direct
les commentaires sportifs du parent
l'heure inconnues
[Applaudissements]
elmander terre le parent l'heure
inconnue est partout il est sur les
stades du rugby les dans les combats de
boxe il est sur les terrains de football
il est partout il est partout seulement
à la même époque
jean antoine se rend compte que c'est
peut-être très bien ce qu'il fait mais
il ne sort pas son micro du stade
il ne va pas à l'extérieur et comme il
est le chef de la rubrique radio au
journal l'intransigeant il se débrouille
avec son journal et qu'il part avec un
matériel insensé pour l'époque il y
avait un mât nos rétractable en bambou
qui servait l'antenne qui était de 18
mètres de long qu'ils ne pourraient pas
rentrer dans les villages de poids peut
aller dans certaines villes ne pouvais
pas tourner donc on y arrive finalement
à bord de ce camion a réalisé 55
émission en direct mais sans enregistrer
interviewer les coureurs en 1929
victor fontan et maillot jaune dans les
pyrénées chez lui il brise sa fourche
il perd le tour de france il abandonne
la tsf avec jean antoine et alex viraux
l'annoncent quasiment tout de suite
l'auto nous l'annoncent qu'avec très
très important retard c'est un le
progrès la tsf les zones sont en train
de de damien une première fois le pion
au papier ce tour 1929 gagnée par le
belge maurice de vail qui court pour la
marque al sion est aussi l'apothéose de
la super survient alors que le scandale
l'une des 300 0,29 et combine
catastrophique
un vainqueur met minable qui avait gagné
épuisés grâce à en effet à des achats de
conscience fait part selon son patron
face était qu un amant table le scandale
on a fait gagner un cadavre comment un
maillot jaune aussi facile à dépouiller
at il pu conserver la première place
c'est une sorte de mortification pour
moi de rappeler l'impuissance de
l'organisateur en présence d' incidents
qui émaillent chaque année le tour de
france en mai 1930 des granges
révolutionne sa course de fond en comble
s'il a cessé de croire à une lutte
purement individuels entre coureurs
il n'accepte pas non plus la domination
des équipes de marque de ce constat
n'est une idée géniale un tour de france
par équipes de nationalités différentes
ce qui veut dire combien la porte
complètement tous les constructeurs que
tous les vélos sont achetés par l'auto
cette plaie vélo il fait construire il
ne fait qu on soir à courbevoie par
action mais les achètent sont tous les
mêmes bo sur des vélos jaunes ils
prennent tout en charge tout en charge
aujourd'hui un courage de poser un tas
de petits cadeaux s'engage il n'aura
qu'à se servir tout l'été on lui donnera
sans les mines et un maillot et les
volailles et pour un mois
nous avions le choix entre renoncer au
tour de france où trouver la nouvelle
formule de cette année formule avec
laquelle le coureur est désormais dans
notre main ils sûrs a dit on toujours
des combines mais tandis que celle de
jadis était sans répression sérieuse
possible nous avons commandé tout neuf
un bel indicateurs des chemins de fer
pour renvoyer à paris tous ceux qui
seraient tentés de renouveler les
errements du passé et comme il faut
trouver de l'argent parce que c'est bien
gentil de faire ça il ya la deuxième
idée a coûté quelques passes pour steam
mais qui est commercial c'est
l'invention de la caravane publicitaire
cette révolution dans le financement de
la course initiée par des granges n'a
pas que des raisons éthiques
en effet en 1930 le marché de la
bicyclette semble avoir atteint son
point culminant avec 10 millions de
propriétaires les fabricants de cycles
constatant une baisse des ventes sont
moins enclins à investir dans l'épreuve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
desgrange avant alors l'actuel
sponsoring en faisant appel à des
marques extra-sportives ouvrant les
routes de france un gigantesque panneau
de réclames ambulante qui précède le
peloton des coureurs
[Musique]
je me rappelle toujours tous les grands
matchs que la menier le lion noir
l'union noir qui avait un camion
admirable un superbe très énorme avec au
dessus du toit du camion à lyon un
énorme longtemps majesteux et quand dans
les replis d'une route serpentant on
voulait monter les voitures noyé par les
voitures dans la foule on pouvait
justement nous arriver des paysans sur
son beffroi y est c'était vraiment tout
à fait extraordinaire et puis un peu
fait se serrant bien commencé à demander
de l'argent
auroville étape ce qui ne s'est pas fait
jusqu'à maintenant va donc il a fallu
faire de l'argent et puis on arrive à
compter sur une amélioration des pentes
du journal ce qui s'est passé
bon finalement ça t la réussite totale
les concurrents en prenant les meilleurs
coureurs de meknassi ont bossé libre et
une lutte sévère sur les 4400 km
[Musique]
la formule des équipes nationales
un succès populaire immédiat d'autant
plus que ce sont les français qui mène
le bal
[Musique]
non
le court avec
et
france ne votez pas l'aide voix
40a sur des vélos la notoriété des
coureurs explosent alors grâce à la
radio qui délivrait de ses premières
lourdeur technique devient la reine des
médias sont le tour de france dès le
premier de la journée il y en a pas un
qui s'appelle le maïs et c'est le
premier appareil d'enregistrement qui
existe et voilà que maintenant on peut
enregistrer la voix des coureurs on peut
enregistrer la voix des directeurs
sportifs
on n'est pas obligé de demander aux
coureurs de venir tous les soirs à cette
heure etc on l'enregistrait cinq heures
du soir et on repasse après alors là ou
alors construit en entendant thomas
marine france m'entendre andré laude qui
a un accent parisien qu'un accent du
faubourg avec son robinet
[Musique]
dans les bistrots
on a commencé à mettre des immenses
poste de radio
les gens étaient autour consommer en
même temps donc le patron du bistrot
étaient contents et c'est à partir de
cette époque là quand il ya eu la radio
qu'on a commencé à mettre sur les
ardoises à la porte des vieux bistrot le
résultat de l'étape du jour et
classement général
il mettait ça à la porte de leur mission
pour que les gens viennent consommer
quand le pour commencer bon là un 4h30
l'après midi on s'arrange à passer
devant un café lui aurait où il y aurait
il y aurait les infos vers 4 heures
quatre heures et demie qui a gagné ce
que félicien pas du type à kohat à rouen
naturellement ça se termine au sprint
une fois de plus homme devant l'entrée
du tunnel du galibier que les coureurs
sont en train de gravir pratique le
porteur du maillot jaune qui vient
d'accomplir un retour éblouissant devant
les voitures montant de danse debout sur
ses pédales un rythme extraordinaire
la ligue l'a ratée sur le sol en plus
moi mes cousins et moi bon c'était l'été
ont commencé à s'installer à la campagne
et devant la maison tracer les petites
routes est on est on faisait rouler là
dessus des billes qui était supposée
être être ce pays cher ou lapébie ou bon
enfin moi j'ai été habité enchantée dans
le sens le plus fort du mot par le tour
de france bien que vous n'êtes pas
encore réveillé mais moins d'interroll
déjà champion belge georges briquet dans
internet
dd nous raconte ce qu'il voit qu'il
connaît si bien les contrats qui
faisaient leur nom vient en gardant nos
jambes
il évite à tout le monde
l'arrivée de la radio est vécue comme un
traumatisme par la presse écrite
au point que pression est faite sur les
responsables de la tsf pour qu'ils
régulent leurs journaux d'information
parler sur les rythmes de parution des
journaux papiers l'auto enregistre alors
ses plus belles ventes 364 1000
exemplaires par jour durant le tour 1933
remportée par le français se paye cher
dans l'épreuve le cinéma devenu parlant
est bien mieux accueilli que la radio
par l'auto en ce sens qu'il ne menace en
rien le monopole du journal sur la
primeur des informations par les résumés
des tapes passe-temps salle avec une
semaine de décalage
[Musique]
mais surtout la furtivité de la course
entrave à sa mise en spectacle est
battue en brèche par les cinéastes qui
peuvent pénétrer au coeur du peloton
contribuant ainsi à enrichir la légende
des grands viennent les forçats de la
route deviennent des stars
la coqueluche de ce tour 1934 c'est rené
vietto qui va entrer dans la légende
comme un symbole du sacrifice et de
l'abnégation
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à la tête du tourmalet vrai nous est en
tête suivi de tous et matt est encore
bien tôt périph deux premiers au sommet
du tourmalet il faut que l'événement est
suffisamment de force je pense à un
événement qui a beaucoup marqué et qui
sur le coup n'est est apparu comme tout
à fait totalement banal c'est le fait
que dans une descente d'un tour des
pyrénées vietto qui était le jeune du
tour et bien vietto est arrêté et on lui
demande de remonter pour donner sa roue
allemagne qui a cassé sa roue donc j'ai
décidé tout depuis j'ai fait demi-tour
et pédales en arrière seulement des
cours des années à sens inverse alors un
film ans après deux dates
enfin j'ai pédalé au moment moment
échoué germain a fait jour monde de
nouveau je sais plus combien et je la
perçois en train de ranger sa chaîne
le mélange leur père sur un vélo
d'empreintes a dit que le foot revient
topper sur son classement général en
attendant camion dépanneur
alors à qui
le vélo il est parti mais j'étais venu
pour ça je voulais porter plainte pour
vol merveille j'ai laissé tomber dans
les descentes man ayant décollé tout le
monde
dégringolade tombe au mauvais elle
rejoint les deux échappés manou procès
toute allure vers tommy hanson a
magnifiquement foyer du plâtre en
général je me sens parfaitement posée et
j'espère que défendrai mon maillot jaune
avec coeur cet épisode est apparu comme
relativement secondaire et puis au fur
et à mesure dans l'histoire gillet du
tour c'est devenu un épisode magnifier
et vietto est apparue comme une sorte de
saint souplet de légende incarné dans
cette course mais la véritable course la
course entre journalistes bat déjà son
plein une épreuve de vitesse qui
consiste à taper un article dans un
temps record pourrait être le premier à
l'envoyer à son journal
1936 c'est l'année des congés payés
la fréquentation du public et
potentiellement de nouveaux lecteurs sur
le bord des routes prend des proportions
gigantesques
une tente a brisé par les règlements
utilisons le droit d'utiliser les
voitures de la maison et de se reposer
dans nos envies
l'auto n'est pas le seul à vouloir
capter cette nouvelle clientèle
paris soir un quotidien qui tire à 2
millions d'exemplaires s'intéresse de
très près au sport allant jusqu'à
organiser ses propres courses cyclistes
gaston bénac chef de la rubrique
sportive en est l'instigateur halak
sinon on y soit donnée aux blessés une
photographie
l'accident du coureur est tombé et
tables de ping pour le journaliste il
faut que la france entière sachet on ne
regardera pas à la dépense on s'y mettra
même à plusieurs s'il le faut
[Musique]
et voici l'arrivée voulait couvrir
l'étape est terminée on est condamné
pour les reporter pour les photographes
c'est la grande bagarre
gaston pénale en ce moment par le
joaillier leduc n'y a pourtant pas de
quoi rire l'étape sera rude
les dernières photos ont été prises
elles sont immédiatement portés dans des
voitures laboratoire chaque minute
chaque seconde compte vers son village
va donner un souffle étonnant à cette
nouvelle presse à paris soir en
introduisant des images il a déjà un
style complètement lyrique baroque
il est près n'importe quoi il fait des
interviews explosive il est très bon et
à cette dimension lyrique qui était
jusqu'ici essentiellement saluer deux
des grands jégo dit yves ajouter des
images et les images le cinéma est
parlant ça vient dans un contexte les
les spectateurs ont besoin d'image mais
le vrai drame pour l'auto quotidien du
matin c'est que paris soit redonne les
résumés de l'étape et les classements
deux heures après l'arrivée pour ses
lecteurs de la capitale et aux premières
heures du jour pour ses lecteurs de
province la menace d'une perte énorme de
la clientèle pousse des granges et
jacques godet a retardé les arrivées du
tour de france en fin d'après-midi
neutralisant ainsi leurs concurrents et
jacques des raconte bien dans ses
mémoires qu'un jour il faut arriver
gaston bénac qui connaît bien qu est un
ami et beynac ça lui dire mon cher
jacques que vous savez que etc
ce mecs très moche est né par le alors
vous savez mon patron était donc
provoquer les initiateurs de cette
méforme de presse
bon ben on est obligé de prendre une
décision qui vous sera un petit peu
désagréable et il sort la maquette un
journal de sport et
je connais évidemment 21 dimanche qu'il
en est des granges renonce à retarder
les arrivées en cette fin des années 30
rien ne va plus pour l'auto la
concurrence de paris soir a précipité le
chiffre des ventes au niveau de celui
des années 20 mais le pire est à venir
début 39
acculée à la faillite par ses excès de
dépenses en mondanités diverses maurice
godet propriétaire de 80% de la sphère
vel d'hiv et parc des princes compris
est obligé de céder toutes ses parts à
un groupe de presse concurrents
[Musique]
je comprendrais son frère jacques
actionnaires minoritaires réussit
néanmoins conserver le contrôle sur la
ligne éditoriale du journal et sur
l'organisation de la course mais le tour
1939 est un tour au rabais ni les
allemands ni les espagnols ni les
italiens y participent
le 30 juillet le belge sylvère maes
remporte l'épreuve dans un parc des
princes mouchetés l'uniforme l'édition
1940 bien qu'annoncée n'aura jamais lieu
le rideau tombe sur le tour de france
pour sept longues années
[Musique]
henri desgrange le père fondateur n'en
verra jamais la renaissance
je gueulais me racontait quand il a été
le voir quand même en plein débat qui il
a il a été membre visite à des grands
chapeaux mal an environ 20 jours avant
sa mort et il a coulé dans sa d'état
évidemment pitoyable mais des grands
chemins dit jacques je continue à faire
des performances
oui je me chronomètre tous les jours et
aujourd'hui j'ai traversé ma chambre
j'ai pu traverser ma chambre et j'ai
gagné trois secondes par rapport à la
veille
je maintiens mes performances c'est se
dire c'est extraordinaire devant la mort
d'êtres de vouloir encore être un
compétiteur on peut plus que traverser
sa chambre
miss chronomètre ça c'est des granges
c'est tous des anges
alors donc qui meurent à ce pur moment
l'enterrement se paie ramatuelle où il
est enterré
jacques caude et le mandat charles
faraud de prononcer quelques mots
enfin on lui dit non maintenant le
patron c'est vous et maurice belay
arrive tape sur l'épaule de son frère et
lui dit j'ai accueilli le patron
maintenant c'est toi voilà et la
succession de ce fait je vais dire
devant le cercueil de d'henri desgrange
après un essai raté de relancer le
journal depuis lyon jacques goddet
remonte à paris il y est accueilli par
un directeur potiche incertain le jeune
qui lui apprend que le groupe l'auto
vient d'être racheté par un consortium
suisse allemand en fait une façade des
services de propagande nazie
[Musique]
jeudi le jeune homme est face à l'ô j'ai
dit à vos amis allemands que je vais
continuer à faire pas de journal à une
seule condition c'est que je n'entend
jamais parler d'eux qu'ils n'ont jamais
rien demandé qu'on ne voit jamais
personne sinon j'arrête tout aimé qu
avatar est tous avec moi
en attendant le départ pour le critérium
de france de la route
56 coureurs prennent part à cette
épreuve première grande course cycliste
depuis l'armistice le rationnement de
l'essence et la pénurie alimentaire ne
permettent certes plus d'organiser des
courses de longue haleine mais bon an
mal an les ventes de l'auto se
maintiennent d'autant plus que le sport
est l'une des vertus majeur prônée par
la révolution nationale
l'auto sera maréchaliste
la jeunesse va acquérir sur les stades
le goût de l'effort de la lutte tenace
apprendre à obéir sans réticence à
pousser cet esprit d'équipé jusqu'au
sacrifice devenir un homme dans la joie
et l'allégresse et s'il le faut dans la
souffrance
[Musique]
la france commence une autre vie
le maréchal veut lui donner un bain de
purification de plus les autorités
d'occupation oblige loto à ouvrir les
colonnes de sa rubrique d'informations
générales savoir vite à leurs messages
de propagande et entre autres aux avis
d'exécution de résistants
il ya aussi le le jacques goddet de
l'auto pendant la guerre c'est assez
gratiné quand même et moi j'ai trouvé
une des lotos ou harris à la population
aujourd'hui ont été fusillés pour le
trahison pour ceux ci et ce jour là
c'est estienne d'orves en gros lestienne
d'or qui étaient calmes un monsieur
comme 641 et bah moi ça m'a un peu gêné
quand même de travailler dans ce journal
parce que même si on lui est imposé on
avait le choix de ne pas écrire de
partir de faire autre chose
le progrès lyon quelques annonces
arrivent à lyon a cessé sa parution
purement et simplement moi qui ai essayé
d'approfondir un peu ce qu'a fait
jacques goddet je ne peux pas l'accusé
si rouler pendant l'occupation d'avoir
été vraiment un collaborateur mais
surtout dans une presse où on va
vraiment dans le sens de la
collaboration d'une façon générale lui
se tient toujours en réserve en 1942 la
ferveur maréchaliste s'émousse jacques
goddet mais de plus en plus de mauvaise
volonté à ouvrir ses colonnes à la
propaganda staffel malgré la pression
des actionnaires allemands
il ne peut par contre s'opposer à
l'utilisation du vel d'hiv comme lieux
de meetings pour les grand messes pro
nazi
[Musique]
pire il ne peut intervenir lorsque les
16 et 17 juillet 1942 8000 juifs de la
région parisienne sont parqués dans le
vélodrome réquisitionnés par la police
française avant d'être déportés vers les
camps d'extermination
à peine un mois plus tard les services
de propagande de vichy qui souhaite
relancer le tour de france contact
jacques goddet c'était aux yeux des
occupants le symbole une france vivent
une vie normale joyeuse
on m'apportait de la nourriture de
l'essence des bicyclettes des bleus
bicyclettes des voitures de faire des
choses qui était inimaginable à l'époque
et on ressasse debré pourquoi je
refusais je retire julien données
soutirer on la tient je refuse je n'ai
pas voulu organiser le tour de france et
j'ai été aidé heureusement par le fait
que quelqu'un c'est pour ses efforts
pour organiser ce qu'il appelait le
circuit de france je crois ce quelqu'un
c'est jean leulliot un ancien protégé
d'henri desgrange qui sous le patronage
de la france socialiste un journal ultra
collaborateurs organise un ersatz du
tour le circuit kroes
la course à l'autorisation des allemands
de pénétrer en zone non occupée où les
coureurs sont félicités par le président
laval avant de retourner sur paris
kim et avait remporté par et mon loulou
qui précède de plusieurs minutes le
belge françois de ville grand
triomphateur au classement général jean
le lot accompli un acte de haute
trahison
certains on retient et fusilla pas hier
je pense que jean lourd que j'aimais
bien et j'ai du mal à le dire ça fait du
bien à le dire parce que je l'aimais
bien le garçon qui était dans ma voiture
le tour de france qui était près de moi
qui étais le collaborateur près de moi
dans deux pour la rédaction aussi si
jacques desse tenez c'est pas mal ce jeu
il était donc jacques goddet ont été
condamnées à la libération le 11 juin
1944 le tour de paris contre la montre
est la dernière épreuve organisée par le
journal le 17 août 44 l'auto cesse de
paraître définitive
[Musique]
limité c'est pour quand
c'était la bête c'était la joie c'était
on a le redonner le tour de france aux
français
copie nathaniel le divin le surhomme
je dis à ma mère seriez à tellure 1 ghz
quelle étrange travail quelques chèques
cadeaux bijoux
[Musique]
yannick aurait reconnu il ya une
performer venu puis finalement ça a mené
les sera sorti
on posait toujours la même question
alors gare lire affaire il est
imbattable
au leader et déporté le sachant ce seuil
est d'attaquer l'autre axe et c'est
peut-être l'erreur de raymond poulidor
toulouse